wir haben es angekündigt heute ist der
große Tag ich bin heute ein Tag
Praktikant in der Sterneküche und weil
ich weiß dass in gastronomie-küchen und
gerade im guten Küchen wahnsinniger
Druck herrscht Präzision Perfektion
erwartet wird ich bin sehr gespannt Eric
filmt das ganze heute ich würde sagen
wir gehen erstmal rein und ich hole mir
meine Uniform ab mein Outfit mal schauen
so da sind wir Leute wissen natürlich
alle Bescheid moin moin
alles gut bist du bereit ich bin bereit
ist das für mich einmal komplett das
Outfit Joy bis gleich was sagst du was
erwartet mich heute nein Schmerz oder
vielleicht noch das schönste Gefühl der
Welt
geil los geht's wir sehen mich jetzt als
Koch in drei zwei
das finde ich an meinem ersten Tag als
Praktikant
[Musik]
das muss immer gekrempelt sein oder wie
deswegen ist das Rad das muss immer
gekrempelt sein und dann darfst Du
selber entscheiden ob du mit langen oder
Kurzarbeit
aber das muss immer gehen werden
das ist krass das Maximilian Lorenz Logo
das ist der Michel lauscht werden und
das ist wie die Leute hier für den Laden
brennen Alter und ich muss ja heute
mitziehen deshalb los geht's
bei einer gewissen Temperatur eine
gewisse Zeit gegart ja natürlich hart
gekocht
es ist Eiweiß Stock ganz leicht ja und
das Eigelb ist nachher so wachsweich du
nimmst es einmal spürst es einmal ab
nächstes jeden Topf und dann bedecken
wir das nachher mit einem geräucherten
sucht von der Forelle Weizen das durch
der ist quasi ein bisschen versalzt und
dadurch ändert sich nachher die
Konsistenz aus Wachs mit nachher so ein
bisschen kristallin dann ist okay alle
Eier habe ich Zeit nimmt euch Gas geben
okay wir müssen einsetzen und dann war
es auch schon soweit die erste Aufgabe
des Tages ich meine es war klar dass ich
nicht direkt irgendwelche super
komplexen Teller zubereiten müsste aber
ich habe einfach sofort angefangen und
plötzlich war ich mittendrin es geht los
einfach hier zack zack zack ich habe
wirklich direkt so Druck also ich will
natürlich jetzt abliefern Nummer eins
fertig hat geklappt nur noch 30 weitere
[Musik]
man hat dann relativ schnell gemerkt
dass eine besondere Stimmung geherrscht
hat in der Küche also da war einfach in
der Luft weil die Jungs sind einfach
hochkonzentriert absolut professionell
aber trotzdem entspannt auf ihre Art und
Weise dabei und das war sehr
beeindruckend für mich wow
[Musik]
das kriegen wir ja klar
frischer Paul pro knusprig angebraten
neurologisch schon fast so cremig in wie
geht das so eine schöne Pasta zu einer
meeresfrüchtesoße bisschen Zitronensaft
ganz kleines bisschen Parmesan dass das
findet dazu Pino Grigio Füße hochlegen
Sundowner bin ich der Welt das stelle
ich mir vor nach meinem Feierabend und
das Ding ist ich muss es mir vorstellen
weil ich habe gerade erst angefangen so
der Tag hat gemächlich sein Lauf
genommen wir hatten quasi und das habe
ich das später erst richtig verstanden
gerade so ein bisschen so das Vorspiel
so die entspannte Gruppenphase man
bereitet sich ein bisschen vormittags
macht ein paar Vorbereitungen aber was
dann abends kommen sollte konnte ich
wirklich nicht erwarten du hast es
gerade so schön gesagt Mittagsgeschäft
was sagst du zum Mittagsgeschäft
eigenphase wir fangen mit der Produktion
schicken während das nicht das
Restaurant oder das Heinz Hermann und
jetzt geht's halt los heute abend heute
Abend ist halt für uns heute Abend
welcher Teil macht mehr Spaß heute Abend
der Service ist das besser egal
aber jeder weiß was er zu tun hat das
ist na klar rein für mich hat Max bis
jetzt noch zu wenig verkackt
halt super teuer noch
was also so wie ich es verstanden habe
gab es eine Fehllieferung und
es ist jetzt quasi ein Teil vom Fisch
mitgeliefert worden der eigentlich nicht
gebraucht quasi umstrukturiert wie man
das doch noch verwerten könnte also
damit nichts weggeworfen wird damit es
wirtschaftlich Sinn macht
dann siehst du jetzt mit den Fisch das
ist ja nicht durchsichtig es scheint
wohl heikel zu laufen gerade
Frage habe ich wahrgenommen es gab eine
Fehlleitung gerade umdisponiert was man
jetzt damit macht es ist nicht so geil
wie wir uns vorgestellt haben
normalerweise bekommst du ein Fisch wenn
wir uns definiert nehmen hast du quasi
das Fisch für gerade und hast hier quasi
wo die Geräte lang läuft über den Bauch
klappen es ist sehr fein ja und das ist
hier komplett zerrissen auch sehr klein
das heißt wenn ich Dir in Grete wohnte
er die die nächsten vier Jahre hier und
deswegen müssen wir einfach jetzt okay
sagen wir müssen was vom Fischfilet
wegschneiden aber wir können uns nicht
leisten es wegzuschmeißen Problem habe
ich auch ethisch das ist ein Tier ich
bearbeite alles vom Tier arbeitet ja
auch die Haut des Geflügels ja okay
jetzt musst mir dafür eine Lösung finden
und das war nur eine Situation wo die
Jungs einfach mal so irgendwas umgeplant
haben mit dem Ziel halt nicht zu
verschwenden alles zu verwerten den
Produkten Wertschätzung entgegen zu
bringen und um das zu können also um
überhaupt zu verstehen was kann ich denn
ändern wenn das nicht da ist wenn das
nicht klappt muss man wirklich einfach
blind Essen verstehen und das tun die
Jungs deshalb klappt das und das finde
ich sehr beeindruckend einmal max gleich
Backpapier drauf auf das flache Blech
eben dann den kaisergranatschwanz liegen
ihnen so drauf nebeneinander kann sich
ruhig berühren werden
liegen dann noch mal Backpapier drauf
noch mal ein Blech und wenn es dann
schon frosten jetzt kann es natürlich
denken in der Fisch ist nachher gefroren
nicht mehr so geil bei schockfrosten
reicht es nicht dass ich das
Wassermolekül aussehen kann das heißt du
hast eine produktverstechterung und ca 1
bis 1,2% schmecke ich nicht raus aber
ich habe damit eine sehr schöne Sache
ich habe damit keine Überlagerung wenn
du heute nicht das Ding bestellst ist
das ein Tag in der Kühlung stellst du es
morgen nicht vier Tage in der Wohnung
man wird es alt und so kann ich immer
sagen ich habe die beste Qualität mehr
als hauseigene frische konvenience
hergestellt ja einfach mal selbst
schockfrost ich meine die haben ein
eigenes Lagersystem so das braucht ein
gutes Restaurant aber es hat mich schon
beeindruckt dass man nicht Schock
gefrostet kauft sondern dass man um so
den Standard zu waren den man selbst
haben möchte einfach alles selbst machen
eigenes System hat und sich um alles
kümmert genau solche Sachen wollte ich
sehen also ich hatte richtig Lust so
Methoden Tipps und Tricks zu entdecken
um vielleicht diese Dinge auch mal
selbst anwenden zu können
[Musik]
Zwischenfazit zwischen Fazit
Mittagspause
langsam so das erste Drittel ist
abgeschlossen bisher sehr positiv du
stellst dich sehr gut an aber das habe
ich auch schon fast erwartet also wie du
gekocht hast dann war ja klar dass das
heute hier kein Desaster wird sagen die
Jungs dazu ja läuft bisher alles gut er
könnte ein bisschen schneller werden
aber passt alles bestens wir sind alle
zu nett Alter
ja ich glaube jetzt geht's gleich
richtig los heute abend volles Haus
beide Häuser voll das ist ja noch die
Herausforderung es macht also es sind
zwei Restaurants die bedient werden
wollen ne und heute Abend wird das auch
so sein dass du heute Abend die Abbruch
des Sterne Restaurant schickst die
Aprils genau
das klassisch gibt es diesen Gruß aus
der Küche wir finden das einfach
langweilig aber wir machen drei kleine
Gerichte die du eigentlich fast mit dem
Finger snacken kannst ich schicke die
heißt ich bereite sie zu du wirst die
finalisieren anrichten so wie du sie
machen wirst wird der Gast sehr erleben
ich glaube wir können es euch vorstellen
in diesem Moment habe ich dann doch ein
klein bisschen Druck verspürt und das
war aber noch gar nichts im Vergleich
dazu was ich gespürt habe als ich dann
wieder in der Küche war weil die Jungs
die ganze Crew waren die ausgetauscht
plötzlich ganz andere Stimmung präzise
Antworten bisschen lauter geworden alle
und ich war so okay so jetzt bin ich
richtig da jetzt ist der Spaß vorbei
jetzt geht's ab und das lustige ist es
hat sich auch einfach niemand mehr für
mich interessiert so davor haben wir
alle den kleinen Max ein bisschen
beschäftigt hier machen wir das noch mal
das und plötzlich war so strukturiert
stand erst mal eine ganze Weile da und
dann habe ich gesagt so wo kann ich
anpacken paar merk langsam wird es
richtig ernst oder ja ich glaube auch
Alter man merkt schon ist schon leicht
andere Stimme also vorher war wirklich
so Kindergarten ja die Jungs vielleicht
trotzdem locker aus dem Handgelenk aber
für mich wird es jetzt glaube ich
wirklich ernst mach dir keinen Druck Bro
du schaffst das du bist nicht so
versagen wir machen nur Spaß ich will
dass du winstrow ich probiere mich so
gut wie möglich zu machen das auf jeden
Fall okay diese Speise bereite ich jetzt
gleich vor einmal alles mit Dir so
könnte man sagen debrioche dann haben
wir einen Baiser oben drauf wir haben
ein wenig Matjes flambiert Krautsalat
und viel und den Mayo
wo ich in den gesäge wissen dann kam mir
so eine Wolke so im Mund wow so einfach
mal ein bisschen die Stimmung
runterfahren Max konzentriere Dich ne
geht jetzt los gib jetzt die Zeit dafür
sehr sehr viel Geld heute Abend essen zu
dürfen und denkt immer noch mit Schlauch
dann rüber ne wenn du jetzt die Apost
schickst good luck
ich schreibe mir noch mal auf wie ich
was mache Alter ich will jetzt nicht
gleich was vergessen dann Weißkraut
dann
noch Hering
[Musik]
ohne Zwiebeln
ich glaube das heute gibt mir noch mal
eine viel größere Wertschätzung dafür in
solchen Restaurants essen zu dürfen
krank
bedanken uns heute mal bei Eric unter
unserem 4
[Applaus]
also wir müssen uns bedanken eine coole
Erfahrung danke schön dass wir das
machen durften und ihr seid echt ein
cooles Team danke schön danke
nein ich hoffe du hast einigermaßen
zufrieden mit mir ich habe jede Menge
Spaß wir müssen jetzt gar nicht groß
abmonieren mit einem Service ich selbst
werde wahrscheinlich noch irgendwas
einfallen lassen als kleines Dankeschön
wird sie vielleicht mit nach Hause
nehmen die Jacke
hör mal auf ey wirklich das ist eine
große Ehre danke schön noch eine
Kleinigkeit ja weil das heute so gut
gemacht hast wir haben ja drüben noch
ein anderes Lokal wird es eines Tages
sofern du Lust hast die Max Bowl geben
für eine Woche Mama mir dazu kann ich
nicht nein sagen mein eigenes Gericht in
der Straßenküche kommt bald was auf euch
zu geil
geil danke dir und danke euch jetzt gehe
ich essen
und auch jetzt gehe ich wieder essen ich
habe nämlich heute Geburtstag ich bin 25
geworden und ich hoffe dass euch das
Video gefallen hat das ist ein sehr
großes ein schönes wichtiges Video für
mich danke fürs zusehen dass gerne ein
Abo da wenn es euch gefallen hat und bis
zum nächsten Mal ciao